bonjour ça les benjamins ont battu mais
très bien parce qu'ils savent at t vient
d'installer une belle voiture
merci bien très belle merci c'est gentil
ça serait elle présentait une émission
comme tpm pc une pression c'est assez
compliqué parce que ses pmp ses scieries
les clans j'ai foiré de trois
présentations ce que j'ai voulu faire
absolument mariole alors que ça ne
ressemble pas c'est pas moi je peux
faire des blagues bien sûr pas je peux
pas dit mais comme cyril bon il ya des
émissions que tu a regretté de fer est
pêché par orgueil quand je l'avais sur
s'est vite pour faire nouvelle star et
pour maman d'être intégré l'équipe de
syrie j'ai refusé par orgueil bien même
on appris lorsque je suis partie de ces
huit pour aller sur nrj12 et ça ça
aurait pu me coûter beaucoup plus cher
que ça va coûter
comment tu trouves que la téléréalité a
évolué sna où on a continué nous à faire
l'élection de miss y dans les
marseillais ou dans les ans il était à
l'amnesia avec david guetta
forcément il en était plus ancré dans la
réalité aujourd'hui donc tu trouves que
cycle stories c'est fake c'est qu'en
plus que fake est ce qu'il ya des
regrets par rapport à ce que tu as fait
tes ou c'est pas moi moi moi moi là il
devient on m'avait prévenu qu'il fallait
ouvrir les fenêtres avec toi pas se
mentir ça ne sent pas bon
[Musique]
je vais t'en sers défi j'ai un objet
avec moi ah le fameux coussins péteurs
on va aller sur une terrasse de café
faudrait que tu assumes de péter en
public tout à fait hors grave que ça
sent pas bon non c'est pas une blague
c'est gastrique non sincèrement je suis
désolé désolé c'est pour cacher
je ne me répondent par oui ou par non
des émissions que tu referais où tu ne
referai pas d'accord secret story je
leur offrais et en étant plus
interventionniste évidemment le love
story je leur présenterai avec plaisir
parce que j'étais tellement protégés est
tellement dans un tourbillon de succès
que j'en ai même pas profiter nouvelle
star bien sûr je refais rester un grand
bonheur à contre sens c'est le jeu j'ai
le plus aimé faire pour toute ma
carrière
largement soirée à 19h parole jean luc
reichman époque où il m'avait piqué mon
formage d'accord au g20 et mais j'avais
dit à tf1 mais c'est pas un contre sens
que vous allez remettra pas du tout
moment ça ne rend pas du tout mon cul
c'est du poulet la ferme célébrités
chico est un désastre
moi je n'oublierai jamais la visite avec
de la lorraine qui était patron d'hôtel
et arrêté
ouais ça promet quand même coûté à
l'époque je crois 22 millions d'euros à
tf1 et du maïs ont marre ils sont les
années mon mari sont jetés pas pour vous
venez de la musique
ah bah non moins belle musique
[Musique]
j'ai pas si la chanson accrochante mais
moi j'aime chanter à ces dommages assez
dommage c'était la dernière fois des
flèches ignorante de llanelli cela
l'histoire de larry hagman yamani nenê
je suis l'un
si vous rapportez
je suis en général
ils ont chanté le cyclone larry ah oui
comme un bruit et le galop et sont
arrivés de connemara au matinée sur une
croix dorée et si tu avais des émissions
de timbres est présentée mais tu n'as
pas présenté je me réponds oui ou non
ok the voice bien sûr bien me dire à
l'époque gt gt en lice pour garder de
voice le format est arrivé c'était
évidemment la révolution 2.0 du télé
crochet koh lanta oui bien sûr j'aurais
adoré le présenter top chef
ah non casse les couilles tu vas gagner
des millions un génial bien sûr tpm paix
non tpm puisque c'est vraiment syrie
enquête exclusive rien à foot donc
l'exclusif a fait un plateau une situe à
près va au sofitel il ne pourra qu'aider
aventurier a présenté des miss france
alors il était question à l'époque je
remplace jean-pierre ya beaucoup
d'émissions question tu devais remplacer
outils de détection à un moment que je
remplace jean-pierre quand je l'avais
tf1 mais non c'est pas fait c'est des
gros barnum ces magnifiques voilà the
wall
il a été question que je crois que tf1
maintenant verdict est a dit je pense
qu'il faut une crise d'urticaire donc
mon fort boyard il était question très
sympa à faire est bien sûr motus touché
des boulons
[Musique]
j'aimerais que tu me présente les
chroniqueurs tmp façon sic restera comme
ça entre dans la maison exactement
tacoli michel briquet à capter encore
stagiaire à la rtf chaque fois qu'elle a
dit les chiens se pète la thur les
légendes dit qu'elle a fini les négos
dans l'émission mais personne n'a été le
témoin son secret un jour j'ai des
comestibles
c'est isabelle morini-bosc
applaudissements mais là messieurs il a
érigé la teub en véritable art de vivre
est aussi sénateur que moi je suis
toucheront il a déjà formulé une phrase
sans bafouiller mais c'était en 1983 il
était bourré son secret en vrai je suis
plus au sénat michel mr il appelle
isabelle mamie alors qu'il n'a que deux
ans d'ère clar avec qui elle très dur il
pense toujours qu'il aura un prime cette
année leur présenter woolf et non ait
pas une bande son secret je suis
animateur télé mais personne ne le sait
matthieu delormeau grâce à ta gueule
[Musique]
alors allons y arriver
bon j'espère que tu as passé un bon
moment très sympa très sympa merci
beaucoup merci beaucoup plaisir d'offrir
à ces gens et bien tout va bien merci
aux prix
on fêtait pas d'odeur c'est une légende
[Musique]